at around 4:30 a.m. our satellites  detected a storm approaching the Ares 3  mission site on Mars storm had escalated  to severe and we had no choice but to  abort the mission but during the  evacuation astronaut Mark Watney was  killed but it be possible that he's  still alive this is Mark Watney I'm  entering this log for the record and I'm  still alive obviously I have no way to  contact my crewmates it would take four  years for another manned mission to  reach me  in the face of overwhelming odds I'm  left with only one option I'm gonna have  to science the hell out of this okay  let's do the math I got to figure out  how to grow four years worth of food  here on a planet where nothing grows but  if I can't figure out a way to make  contact with NASA none of this matters  anyway Houston be advised we've got a  video message  not won't he's still alive  in your face Neil Armstrong let's go get  our boy  every human being has a Basic Instinct  for that exception  you